65 personnalités ont signé un appel
publié par le journal du dimanche pour
dénoncer je les cite le dénigrement
permanent dont est victime françois
hollande
les artistes comme catherine deneuve
juliette binoche ou encore benjamin
biolay des sportifs comme yohann diniz
urgentiste patrick peloux vous auriez
signé cet appel
absolument je trouve que cet appel je
sais pas qui en est l'initiateur mais en
tout cas il est bienvenu et notamment à
françois fillon
aucune économie moderne d'un taux de tva
à 22% de gaulle avait été interrogé sur
ce concept de primaire
je le dis en toute amitié à françois
fillon on ne supprimera pas 500 mille
six cent mille emplois de fonctionnaires
dans les cinq ans qui viennent
il avait même été très cruel il avait
dit la primaire ça consiste en réalité à
choisir en gros le plus inodore incolore
et sans saveur pour cette critique signe
son impuissance et justifie ma
candidature premier des trois favoris à
voter françois fillon dans la frénésie
médiatique bordelais
le monde est passé en a que c'est beau
lui ne va pas faire la queue l'ancien
chef de l'état se présentent directement
devant les assesseurs
je suis toujours confiant aux préfets
les électeurs qui décident sont les
chiffres officiels de la haute autorité
de cette primaire françois fillon est
donc le grand gagnant du soir 44,1 pour
cent
nicolas sarkozy a été la cible de tout
le monde en russie l'avait cette
spécificité d'avoir été ancien président
et détruit on est sanctionné de faire
toujours les mêmes promesses les de ne
pas les tenir quand on est au pouvoir et
ça finit par se voir façon l'avait dit
et ça s'est vu manifestement je voterai
pour françois fillon au second tour de
la primaire
en fonction des réponses qui me seront
apportés par alain juppé par françois
fillon
eh bien je déciderai du soutien à
apporter ou pas à telle ou telle que
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour alain juppé
mais les choix politiques de françois
fillon motion plus proche
au deuxième tour je soutiendrai alain
juppé pour défendre mes idées
j'ai décidé de continuer le combat
je n'ai aucune amertume chez nous aucune
tristesse et je souhaite le meilleur
pour mon pays pour vous mes chers
compatriotes et pour celui qui aura
conduit re ce pays que j'aime tant
j'ai une pensée particulière pour
nicolas sarkozy
le président de la la droite a donné une
bonne image
j'étais heureux de participer à ce
combat
au revoir à tous